je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
pour cette audition sur les mesures de
soutien et de relance de notre économie
dans cette période de crise sanitaire
qui persistent et de crise économique
qui je le rappelle est la plus
importante que la france ait eu beaucoup
l'oublient
mais les chiffres de récession nous
n'avons pas connu d'aussi grave depuis
des décennies ce qui explique aussi les
niveaux d'endettement auquel nous sommes
parvenus et les mesures exceptionnelles
que nous avons prises avec le président
de la république et le premier ministre
depuis le début de cette crise nous
avons aujourd'hui des chiffres sanitaire
qui restent préoccupants comme vous le
savez nous aurons des décisions à
prendre avec le premier ministre et le
président de la république dans les
jours qui viennent je tiens simplement
rappeler que rien n'est arrêté que nous
suivons l'évolution de la situation
épidémique au jour le jour pour prendre
les meilleures décisions
le moment venu en fonction de cette
situation épidémique et de la nécessité
aussi de protéger les français contre
les conséquences de la crise économique
pour garder du temps pour les questions
que vous aurez à me poser je voudrais
simplement passer des messages très
simple sur la stratégie qui était la
nôtre depuis le premier jour de cette
crise parce que je crois que elle se
traduit par beaucoup de lisibilité et
beaucoup de constance la lisibilité elle
repose sur un choix qui a été fait
choix qui a été fait par d'autres pays
européens de protection de tous les
salariés et de toutes nos entreprises
depuis le premier jour de cette crise et
je lui comme ministre de l'économie et
des finances est un choix qui n'était
pas évident à faire mais que nous avons
fait en faisons tout simplement un bilan
des coûts et des avantages de cette
stratégie le coût de cette stratégie
c'est de la dépense d'argent public bien
entendu mais un coup j'y reviendrai qui
est modéré étant donné la situation des
taux d'intérêt l'énorme avantage c'est
que nous préservons des compétences que
la france a mis des années à acquérir et
nous évitons tout simplement un tsunami
de faillite
nous avons eu en 2020 moins de faillites
qu'en 2019 alors même que nous étions
confronté à la plus grave crise
économique depuis 1929 35000 faillite en
2020 près de 50000 en 2019
donc le choix stratégiques il est là qu
est ce qu est le plus coûteux avoir des
millions de chômeurs supplémentaires et
des dizaines de milliers de faillite
qu'ils auraient fait perdre des
compétences extrêmement difficile à
acquérir des technologies extrêmement
difficiles à protéger ou au contraire
emprunter de l'argent public pour
pouvoir protéger nos salariés et nos
entreprises nous avons fait c'est second
choix protéger nos salariés nos
entreprises nos compétences
je pense que c'est plus juste mais je
pense aussi que c'est plus efficace
économiquement car cela nous permettra
de rebondir plus rapidement lorsque la
crise sanitaire sera derrière nous pour
vous donner mon évaluation des mois à
venir je veux aussi vous dire que malgré
les jours difficiles dans lesquelles
nous sommes malgré la lassitude des
français que je comprends malgré
l'épuisement qui est lié à ces
restrictions sanitaires au couvre-feu à
18 heures qui n'est pas une mesure
anodine c'est une mesure qui pèse sur la
vie de chacun
je sais convaincu que dans la deuxième
partie de l'année 2021 une fois que nous
aurons je l'espère la crise sanitaire
derrière nous que la vaccination aura
produit tout son effet la france
montrera des capacités de rebond
économique exceptionnelle j'en suis
convaincu et je veux dire à tous les
français qui nous écoutent oui le moment
que nous traversons est particulièrement
difficile
j'ai toujours indiqué depuis la fin de
l'année dernière que ces premières
semaines et ses premiers mois de
21 serait dur mais nous avons devant
nous dans les mois qui viennent d'ici la
fin de l'année
la perspective d'un vrai une
redressement économique et notre
responsabilité est à la fois de protéger
les secteurs qui sont les plus touchés
par la crise et dans le même temps de
préparer ce rebond de l'économie
française en engageant immédiatement
sans délai les mesures de relance que
nous avons déjà définies et adoptées au
sénat comme à l'assemblée nationale
ces deux volets de protection et de
relance sont d'autant plus
indispensables que l'économie française
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une économie
ces deux économies vous avez une
économie qui est très durement touché
par la crise
vous avez des secteurs qui sont fermées
des restaurants des bars vous avez des
établissements qui tourne avec 10 20 30
% de taux de remplissage pour les hôtels
vous avez des secteurs comme
l'événementiel le sport la culture qui
sont sinistrées et qui souffrent
terriblement et qui souffre encore plus
de l'absence de perspectives parce que
nous ne pouvons pas donner de calendrier
qui ne serait pas raisonnable donner de
calendrier
c'est cette économie là qu'il faut aider
en priorité et qui doit savoir que aussi
longtemps que la crise durera nous
serons là et elle pourra bénéficier des
mesures de protection sur lesquelles je
reviendrai
et puis vous avez une deuxième
économique il faut pas oublier parce que
évidemment on en parle moins mais c'est
l'économie qui marche bien c'est le
secteur du luxe qui commence à rebondir
c'est l'agroalimentaire c'est le
bâtiment et les travaux publics
qu'embaucher 20000 personnes de plus
l'année dernière qui ne l'avait embauché
précédemment c'est les 485 milles
apprentis qui ont été embauchés dans ces
secteurs en 2020 soit le meilleur
chiffre que nous ayons obtenue en termes
d'apprentissage depuis des années pour
ne parlons pas de l'économie française
globalement la réalité de l'économie
française c'est deux économies très
différentes l'une qui est très durement
touché par la crise sanitaire
l'autre qui a déjà commencé à rebondir
et qui doit être accompagnée également
pour rebondir encore plus fort et créer
les emplois dont nous avons besoin
s'agissant du volet de protection il
repose depuis le premier jour sur quatre
dispositifs que nous adaptons et qui
sont les 4 piliers de la protection
économique de la france
le premier c'est le fonds de solidarité
n'avons cessé de le faire évoluer ce
était à l'origine un fonds universel
protégeant tous les secteurs de
l'économie
nous l'avons fait évoluer pour se
concentrer sur les secteurs qui sont les
plus touchés l'hôtellerie les cafés la
restauration le monde du tourisme et
pour l'élargir vers des entreprises de
taille plus importante car chacun voit
bien que un groupe de restaurateurs dans
une ville comme lyon ou dans une ville
comme paris dans une grande métropole
un restaurateur qui avait trois ou
quatre établissements les premiers mois
de la crise il peut tenir parce qu'il a
des réserves financières de la
trésorerie
mais au fur et à mesure de la crise
économique s'installe dans la durée et
que des mesures de l'instruction
sanitaire s'installera j'irai lui aussi
a besoin de soutien j'ai annoncé hier
que nous allions débloquer un prêt
garanti par l'état de près d'un demi
milliard d'euros pour accor un vaste
accord un veste au mois de mars ou avril
2020 n'avait pas besoin de cet argent de
cette trésorerie tout simplement parce
qu'il y avait l'été devant des
perspectives de reprise mais maintenant
que nous nous installons dans une crise
de longue durée même des groupes comme
accor un geste ont besoin du soutien de
l'état
donc nous avons fait évoluer le fonds
solidarité qui a représenté 13 milliards
d'euros de dépenses en 2020 et qui a
concerné près de deux millions
d'entreprises principalement des très
petites entreprises et des pme
c'est dire si ce fonds serait d'arrêter
a été un des piliers absolument
essentiel de la réponse à la crise
il reste aujourd'hui un des piliers
essentiels de la réponse à la crise
c'est la raison pour laquelle je le
redis nous n'avons cessé de l'adapter et
d'augmenter aussi les indemnités qu'ils
versent pour protéger des secteurs
concernés
le deuxième volet de protection
c'est l'activité partielle 28 milliards
d'euros dépensés en 2020 qui ont
concerné jusqu'à 8 millions de salariés
au moment où le dispositif a été le plus
développé je rappelle que lors de la
précédente crise nous n'avions pas
adopter ces dispositifs d'indemnisation
du chômage partiel et que alors même que
la france avait été un peu moins touchée
que son voisin allemand elle avait eu
plus de chômeurs parce qu'elles ne
disposaient pas de ce filet de sécurité
avec le chômage partiel
je pense que nous avons tiré toutes les
leçons de la crise de 2008 2009 en
mettant en place le dispositif
d'activité partielle qui est le plus
généreux en europe le plus protecteur en
europe et qui nous a évité des vagues
entières de licenciement au cours des
mois passés
le troisième pilier c'est le prêt
garanti par l'état 135 milliards d'euros
ont été décaissés
ils ont concerné 650 mille entreprises
et je rappelle qu'il continue à faire
l'objet de sollicitations de la part de
certains secteurs qui sont les plus
touchés c'est dire si là aussi c'est un
pilier essentiel
je tiens à dire sur ces prêts garantis
par l'état que nous avons obtenu des
banques françaises et je tiens à les en
remercier parce qu'elles ont fait preuve
de sens des responsabilités que la durée
totale de six ans qui comprend
l'amortissement complet du prêt garanti
par l'état puis sentant non pas une
année + 5 avec le début du remboursement
du capital au bout d'un an
mes deux années plus 4 il est donc
possible et c'est désormais un droit
pour toutes les entreprises quelle que
soit leur taille qui serait décalé le
premier remboursement de leurs prêts
garantis par l'état d'un an
supplémentaire
chacune a la possibilité de le faire
une pme pays qui emprunte et 150 mille
deux cent mille trois cent mille euros
en mars ou en avril
2020 et qui aurait dû commencer à
rembourser son capital à partir de mars
ou avril 2021 pourra de droit je dis
bien de droit le rembourser à partir de
mars ou avril 2029
alors vous me direz que cela renforce le
poids des échéances qui ne se calculent
plusieurs quatre ans sur cinq ans mais
sur quatre ans je suis prêt à regarder
pour certains secteurs qui continuent à
être les plus touchés par la crise et
pour lesquels les montants des prêts
sont les plus importants si un
échéancier plus étendue serait possible
j'engagerai les décident les discussions
avec la commission européenne pour
étudier dans certains secteurs
spécifiques
si cet étalement est envisageable je
donne un exemple dont j'ai parlé déjà
avec le président reynal c'est
l'aéronautique
vous avez des pme qui ont engagé des
prêts garantis par l'état très important
qui se chiffrent parfois en millions
d'euros qui voit arriver cgc ans avec
beaucoup d'inquiétude et qui avaient
tablé sur une reprise du trafic aérien
dans les mois qui viennent chacun voit
bien que la persistance de la crise
sanitaire et la mutation du virus
éloigne encore davantage le retour à la
normale du trafic aérien
il me paraît donc légitime de tenir
compte de cette réalité sanitaire pour
étudier avec la commission européenne
dans le secteur aéronautique pour les
sous traitants qui sont aujourd'hui les
plus menacés un étalement plus long du
prêt garanti par l'état je m'engage
comme se défait à toulouse à étudier cet
étalement pour le secteur de
l'aéronautique avec la commission
européenne
c'est très important parce que derrière
ces les compétences hors normes qui sont
en jeu c'est des ouvriers qualifiés
c'est des ingénieurs cd savoir faire que
nous avons mis des années à acquérir et
rien ne serait pire que de voir des
entreprises sous-traitantes de
l'industrie aéronautique fermé parce que
nous n'aurions pas donner un bol d'air
financier supplémentaire
enfin le dernier instrument de cette
protection se sont les exonérations de
charges qui ont représenté 4 milliards
d'euros en 2020 je pense que ce qui a
fait la force et l'efficacité de la
réponse économique française à la crise
c'est la simplicité de ces dispositifs
c'est l'adaptation de ces dispositifs
au fur et à mesure de la crise pour
qu'il réponde aux besoins des
entreprises
et c'est en troisième lieu la certitude
pour les entreprises que nous
maintiendrons ces dispositifs aussi
longtemps que cela sera nécessaire cette
stratégie a été efficace nous n'en
changerons pas nous maintiendrons ces
quatre dispositifs nous continuerons à
les adapter à la réalité de la crise
économique et nous donnons la certitude
au monde économique qu'ils seront
maintenus aussi longtemps que cela sera
nécessaire
je rappelle que ces dispositifs ont
également permis de protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages
vous avez d'un côté une perte de pnb est
de l'ordre de 10 ou 11 points en 10 11
points il est probable que nous
puissions révisé dans un sens plus
favorable
les chiffres de la récession pour 2020
qui sera sans doute moindre que les -10%
que nous avions annoncée grâce aux
capacités de redressement l'économie
française au troisième trimestre et au
mois de décembre enfin il reste que
c'est une récession très violente
au regard de ces -11%
vous mettez la stabilité du pouvoir
d'achat des français
c'est bien la preuve que ces dispositifs
ont été efficaces je n'oublie pas mais
en moins car croyez moi avec mes équipes
nous regardons tout cela chaque jour
avec la plus grande attention que là
aussi ce chiffre de stabilité du pouvoir
d'achat cache des situations très
différentes que les 100 milliards
d'euros d'épargné qui ont été mis de
côté par les français au cours de
l'année 2020 cache des situations très
différentes et qu'il y as pour des
centaines de milliers de français
des millions de nos compatriotes qui
sont les plus fragiles les moins
qualifiés qui ont perdu leur emploi
des situations qui sont
extraordinairement difficile et que nous
sommes tout à fait prêts je pense à ce
qui concerne les jeunes étudiants je
pense à ce qui concerne les femmes
seules aux personnes qui ne sont très
peu qualifiés s'il ya besoin le moment
venu de mesures de soutien
complémentaire parce que derrière la
réalité ces chiffres globaux
il y à des situations individuelles très
différentes et nous en avons conscience
donc s'il ya besoin à un moment donné de
mesures complémentaires pour ces
personnes qui sont les plus touchés par
la crise qui sont les premières victimes
et qui sont souvent celles qu'on entend
le mois nous sommes évidemment ouverts à
des mesures complémentaires pour ces
personnes-là ces mesures seront donc
maintenus
elles ont un coût sur les finances
publiques que vous connaissez avec un
niveau de dette qui approche les cent
vingt pour cent de notre richesse
nationale
je veux profiter cette audition pour
dire que les français n'ont pas
d'inquiétude à avoir sur le financement
de notre dette et je veux juste donner
l'appui de cette affirmation
quelques chiffres s'agissant du
financement sur le marché de la levée de
dette nous avons levé en 2020 290
milliards d'euros de dette à moyen et
long terme
le taux moyen de ses 290 milliards
d'euros de dette à moyen et long terme a
été de -0 14%
nous empruntons à taux négatifs la
dernière levée de dette ce que nous
avons fait sur les marchés pour les
obligations du trésor à 10 ans était à
moins 0,33 pour cent nous avons fait une
levée de dette la semaine dernière sur
une maturité exceptionnelle à 50 ans
nous avons demandé 7 milliards d'euros
nous avons eu un livre d'ordres à 75
milliards d'euros c'est à dire plus de
dix fois ce dont nous avions besoin en
termes de financement et le taux
d'intérêt étaient à 0 59%
j'imagine que les ménages français qui
nous écoutent aimerait pouvoir emprunter
de l'argent pour leur logement à 0 et 2
59% à maturité de 50 ans
tout cela pour dire que nous n'avons pas
de difficultés de financement que les
taux reste très bas ils sont négatifs
pour l échéance à 10 ans et que le taux
moyen de -0 14 est inférieur de 20
points de base au taux moyen de 2019 qui
s'établissait à +0 11% - 0,14 taux moyen
en 2020 +0 11 taux moyen en 2010 9 20
points de base supérieur en 2010 9 par
rapport à 2010 dernier élément d'analysé
pardon pour tous ces chiffres mais je
pense qu'ils sont importants pour
éclairer la commission nous avons
aujourd'hui l'écart de taux d'intérêt
entre la france et l'allemagne le spread
qui est le plus bas de ces dernières
années
j'insiste simplement au passage pour
dire que si nous avons des taux aussi
bas une signature aussi crédible c'est
que la france s'engage sans aucune
ambiguïté à rembourser sa dette et que
rien ne serait plus dommageable à la
qualité de la signature française que de
laisser entendre que nous pourrions ne
pas rembourser notre dette nous
rembourserons notre dette nous les
rembourserons le moment venu
c'est-à-dire lorsque la crise sanitaire
sera d'ailleurs nous nous la
rembourseront par une croissance qui
sera de retour je l'espère d'ici la fin
de l'année 2021 avec un capacité de
rebond je le redis qui est très
puissante dans l'économie française
nous le rembourserons par la maîtrise
des finances publiques qui devra revenir
d'actualité lorsque les circonstances
économiques nous ne permettrons et nous
les rembourserons vous connaissez ma
conviction sur ce sujet par un certain
nombre de mesures structurelles qui
doivent rendre notre modèle social plus
soutenable du point de vue financier je
pense en particulier à la question des
retraites
j'insiste enfin pour dire que ce soit de
protection et d'un choix qui a été fait
par tous les états européens
c'est un choix collectif et ce qui fait
aussi la solidité et la crédibilité des
décisions que nous avons prises et
qu'elles ont été prises en coordination
étroite
avec les autres partenaires européens en
particulier l'allemagne
d'un autre côté nous devons aussi
préparer le rebond de l'économie
française avec la relance quelques mots
sur la relance la première chose sur
laquelle je veux insister c'est que nous
n'avons pas attendu le début de l'année
2021 pour engager la relance les crédits
sont déjà engagées depuis la fin 2020
nous avons engagé 10 milliards d'euros
de crédits sur les 100 milliards d'euros
du plan de relance en 2020 et ne plaisir
de recapitaliser la sncm pour qu'elles
puissent financer son plan fret financer
les rénovations de ligne et donc
moderniser cet équipement d'un grand
service public auquel nous sommes tous
je pense très attaché il y a également
dans ses décaissements le plan de
soutien aux jeunes les mesures de
soutien à l'apprentissage qui ont montré
leur efficacité je le rappelle près d'un
demi million d'apprentis qui ont été
embauchés en 2020
la rénovation des logements privés avec
ma prime rénove qui démarre très
fortement et la transformation notre
industrie avec en particulier le plan de
digitalisation des pme qui est
absolument indispensable pour rattraper
notre retard nous avions prévu 280
millions d'euros grâce à un crédit
d'impôt pour la digitalisation des pme
je rappelle que nous aurons sans doute
800 millions d'euros de crédits
décaissés sur la digitalisation des pme
tellement l'appel a été suivi de
propositions de la part des pme qui
étaient en attente de ce type de
dispositif deuxième chose sur laquelle
je veux insister c'est que cette relance
est clé pour transformer notre modèle
économique
réussir la décarbonation ai les clés
aussi pour ouvrir de nouvelles filières
et de nouvelles chaînes de valeur en
france c'est un enjeu absolument
stratégique
la france est trop reposé sur ses
lauriers elle avait trois quatre grandes
filières industrielles qui lui
permettait d'avoir un excédent
commercial sur ses seules filières mais
un déficit commercial global
et il n'a pas su renouveler ces filières
de valeur elle n'a pas su renouveler ses
chaînes de valeur c'est une erreur
stratégique qui étaient commises depuis
des années c'est très bien d'avoir une
filière du luxe qui se porte très bien
tant mieux
c'est un motif de fierté nationale c'est
très bien d'avoir une industrie
agroalimentaire puissante l'ancien
ministre d'agriculture que je suis lié
profondément attaché c'est très bien
d'avoir une filière viticole qui est
très puissante et une filière
aéronautique et qui fait partie avec
boeing des filières aéronautiques les
plus avancées et les plus pertinentes du
globe simplement quand vous avez un
virus qui empêche les gens de voler
votre filière aéronautique est en grande
difficulté
quand vous avez des sanctions
américaines sur le vin votre filière
viticole est en grande difficulté et au
bout du compte il ne vous reste plus
quasiment que des filières du luxe pour
apporter des excédents commerciaux à la
france il est irresponsable de reposer
faire opposé la croissance française et
nos capacités d'excédent commercial
uniquement sur des filières qui en tout
dix vingt ou trente ans d'existence
il faut savoir renouveler ces filières
les valoriser parce qu'elles sont
exceptionnelles et qu'elles sont un
motif de fierté mais ouvrir de nouvelles
filières et de nouvelles chaînes de
valeur pour la france je pense
évidemment à tout le domaine de la santé
des biotechnologies de l'immunothérapie
je pense qu'on pourra en reparler parce
que c'est aussi peut-être une des leçons
qu'on peut tirer de ce qui s'est passé
en france
récemment je pense aux calculs
quantiques
je pense à l'hydrogène je pense aux
batteries électriques
toutes ces filières et toutes ces
chaînes de valeurs vont nous permettre
de recréer des capacités de création de
richesse dans notre pays et c'est
maintenant que ça se joue c'est
maintenant qu'il faut investir
si nous voulons que la sortie de la
crise nous puissions avoir une économie
qui soit plus compétitive et plus
décarbonés et c'est bien notre objectif
grâce à ce plan de relance avoir une
économie plus compétitive et plus des
cargos
troisième et dernière remarque que je
tiens à faire je vois que certains me
disent mais sans milliard d'euros c'est
pas assez il faudrait rajouter un
deuxième plan de relance à 100 milliards
d'euros
je vais vous dire essayons déjà de
décaisser le maximum de ces 100
milliards d'euros du plan de relance dès
c'est un défi considérable parce que
vous êtes tous ici les élus locaux comme
je le suis moi même et que vous savez
que entre l'annnonce du crédit et le
moment où il va réellement l'entreprise
qui en a besoin
il faut que le dossier soit instruit
faut qu'il y ait un appel d'offres il
faut que l'argent arrive jusqu'à
l'intermédiaire qui est peut être par
exemple la banque publique
d'investissement et puis faut gridda
banque publique d'investissement jusqu'à
l'entreprise
ça peut prendre beaucoup de temps et
parfois trop de temps mon obsession est
la bonne exécution du plan de relance
j'y consacre beaucoup de temps chaque
semaine avec mes équipes
l'essentiel aujourd'hui est d'abord de
décaisser c'est 100 milliards d'euros le
plus rapidement possible je le redis si
nous voyons peu les conditions
continuent de se dégrader qui peut y
avoir besoin ici ou là de mesures
complémentaires pour ceux qui sont le
plus touchés par la crise nous sommes
ouverts à toutes les propositions mais
je pense que quand on gère une crise
aussi importante que celle là il faut
avoir des priorités
ma priorité est la bonne exécution de
plans de relance qui était adoptée par
le parlement
le décaissement le plus rapide possible
de ces 100 milliards d'euros mon
objectif est d'avoir les quais c'est au
minimum
je lis bien au minimum 40 milliards sur
les 100 milliards d'ici la fin de
l'année 2021
merci monsieur le ministre avant de
donner la parole à l'ensemble de nos
collègues je me tourne vers le
rapporteur général pour quelques
premières questions et observations
oui merci et merci messieurs présents
merci monsieur le ministre
moi je j'apprécie la prestation ou d'une
et serge apprécié le volontarisme que
vous déployez et je fais partie de ceux
comme beaucoup qui ont soutenu le
gouvernement et je ne veux donc pas ni
douches et votre optimisme et parfois
même votre enthousiasme
je comprends que dans des situations
difficiles il ya aussi des positions à
tenir et il ya des lignes notamment au
niveau de la confiance de l'opinion des
acteurs économiques
et aujourd'hui même de l'europe
je crois néanmoins je vais illustré par
quelques questions plus précises que
nous avons collectivement et puisque
vous êtes aux affaires nous avons un
devoir de lucidité de la situation et de
vérité l'endroit des français
la lucidité c'est pour moi de faire
attention à ce que l'enthousiasmé ne
soit pas trop débordant d'un argent qu
aujourd'hui y compris à vous entendre ce
serait de l'argent facile je l' ai dit
plusieurs fois c'est la valse des
milliards il pleut des milliards
l'argent ne coûte pas puisque on
emprunte même à des taux négatifs on
emprunte à 50 ans avec des taux
exceptionnels enfin je pense qu'ils sont
aussi des taux variables et hier avant
la crise sanitaire le monde était
différent donc je pense que la vérité
est entre les deux et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense que nous devons à
la fois affiché affirmer une volonté
dans une crise sanitaire planétaire on
pensait qu'il y aura un épisode
et quand tu y compris sur le terrain ici
on disait il y aura peut-être un
deuxième jaune au nom que nenni c'est
pas 2 c 3
et on voit les difficultés de la
vaccination est aujourd'hui où la vidéo
dans vos propos vous dites quand la
vaccination a produit ses effets ce que
tout le monde souhaite
et donc je pense que il faut aussi
tracer des perspectives sur les efforts
qui sont aujourd'hui consentis
collectivement parce que les états c'est
cette des finances publiques mais c'est
aussi des contributions les
contributions elles sont acquittées par
un certain nombre d'acteurs avec des
parts variables
vous avez dit très subtilement dans les
mots qu'il faudrait envisager des des
réformes et notamment sur les retraites
vous l'avez évoqué je pense
effectivement qu'il ya un temps pour
tout il est encore certainement trop tôt
pour être précis mais je pense que nous
serons attendus collectivement sur ce
devoir de vérité que ce soit sur la
manière dont dans un premier temps on
accompagne et ensuite la manière dont tu
ensemble on s'acquittera de cet effort
exceptionnel qui à mon avis engendrera
que ça plaise ou non des efforts
exceptionnels notamment de celles et
ceux qu'ils seront le plus en capacité
de le faire sans freiner le
développement économique
je crois que nous ne pouvons pas dire
autre chose parce que nous n'avons pas
le droit de lui que moi je ne veux pas
berner les français
je pense que vous non plus et nous avons
donc cette exigence de vérité alors je
vais maintenant rapidement mais si oui
monsieur le ministre je pense que les
chiffres sont une chose ils sont têtus
et ils sont la réalité du quotidien
je pense qu'on a aussi besoin de temps
en temps et vous nous donner aujourd'hui
l'occasion y compris par votre propos
liminaire d'échangés peut-être plus en
direct et en face à face sur l'état
d'esprit des français dont vous mesurez
je crois à la fois le doute et les
souhaits pour eux de voir une sortie du
tunnel avec une véritable perspective et
le climat actuel est un peu complexe
pour trouver cette cette lumière au bout
du tunnel
je voulais revenir très rapidement vous
avez abordé les
les prêts garantis par l'état je pense
vous avez donné un certain nombre
d'éléments de réponse moi je propose en
tous les cas que des informations
claires soient données aux entreprises
lorsqu'elles vont faire bouger le 1 + 5
en 2 + 4 et les informations claires
c'est vous en est où qu'est-ce que vous
des quais c'est ça vous coûte combien
parce que vous savez que c'est parfois
aussi une manière de mettre la poussière
sous le tapis
et puis comme chaque année plus ça dure
je dirais plus le montant est important
en bourse et donc il faut faire
attention que ce ne soit pas dans deux
ou trois ans un frein ce matin le
gouverneur de la banque de france le
disait qu' il est estimé entre quatre et
demi et 6 % des entreprises qui
pourraient connaître des désillusions
pour notre économie
avec ce changement voilà donc moi je
pense en tout cas
et puis il peut y avoir un petit sujet
également la question c'est est ce que
vous envisagez alors vous avez dit on
peut aménager mais éventuellement de
convertir certains pge en subventions
sur le fond de solidarité vous avez dit
beaucoup de choses
moi je vais ajouter un élément non pas
technique
celui ci dans le fond celui d'arrêter on
a fait ici au sénat une proposition de
loi sur un partenariat public privé avec
le monde de l'assurance pour essayer de
garantir les frais fixes des entreprises
vous avez été enthousiaste
puis j'ai cru comprendre enfin que le
cas vous avez fait déclaration
considérant que le dossier était bouclé
qu'on n'en parlait plus je vous invite à
reconsidérer votre position je pense
parce que finalement nous aurons besoin
de trouver des solutions je sais pas de
quoi l'avenir est fait mais je trouve en
tout les cas en plus juste une forme un
peu de mépris à l'endroit de haies et du
monde de l'entreprise et des
parlementaires
troisième élément troisième question sur
les prêts participatifs
lors de l'examen du plf
le gouvernement nous avait assuré qu' il
était sur le point de trouver un accord
sur les prêts participatifs avec la
commission européenne pour le mois de
décembre
à ce stade c'est toujours pas le cas
donc pouvez vous nous dire où
sont les discussions quels sont les
points à trancher sur le plan de relance
si j'ai bien tenu mais compte le plf
2021 prévoyait 14 milliards d'euros
devant être dégagées dès 2020 le 21
janvier vous avez fait à 2,11 milliards
tout à l'heure de 10 au titre de 2020
pouvez vous nous indiquer quels
dispositifs dans les prévisions n'ont
pas été confirmées enfin je terminerai
par la territorialisation parce que je
pense que c'est également un sujet
important
on a un tableau de bord le gouvernement
depuis du blues janvier commence à
signer des accords régionaux de relance
provence alpes côte d'azur occitanie ça
va se dérouler comme avec les autres
régions mais je vais plus loin
ces contrats devront être me semble-t-il
coordonnée avec la nouvelle génération
des contrats de plan état région
nous allons à vendre et nous avons des
contrats de relancer la transition
énergétique avec les intercommunalités
les départements quelle est en fin de
compte la part du plan de relance de 100
milliards qui est définie et décidées
par l'état et ses opérateurs et quelle
est la part qui va être défini en
coopération avec les collectivités
puisque dans ces accords il y aura des
cofinancements donc quel est le
financement additionnel à ses 100
milliards que vous attendez des
collectivités monsieur le ministre je
vous propose de répondre si vous voulez
bien en retraite en général que nous
ouvrirons le débat
alors monsieur le rapporteur général
beaucoup de questions tout important
d'abord sur l'état d'esprit des français
je peux me faire juge des français je
pense que ça n'est pas mon rôle
je veux simplement faire part de ma très
grande admiration devant le sens des
responsabilités dont font preuve
l'immense majorité des français et
devant leur capacité à résister à des
temps qui sont extraordinairement
difficile pour eux
on dit très souvent voilà les français
peuple indisciplinés et chaque fois on y
va de ses remarques sur nos compatriotes
c'est à dire sur nous mêmes
la réalité c'est qu'il respecte dans
leur immense majorité des règles
sanitaires qui sont contraignantes
ils font preuve de sens des
responsabilités
ils font preuve de beaucoup de
solidarité les uns entre les autres et
je le voit notamment dans le secteur
économique qui est le mien ou à tous les
niveaux il y a un vrai sens des
solidarités qui se déploie dans une
filière entre les donneurs d'ordre et
les sous-traitants dans les secteurs
financiers je lui ai indiqué si les
banques n'avaient pas été là pour
répondre les prêts garantis par l'état
je pense que nous n'aurions pas pu
résister à cette crise donc moi je veux
vraiment avec beaucoup de gravité salué
la manière dont les français traverse
cette épreuve je trouve que cela force
l'admiration
ensuite quelles sont les perspectives je
vais très honnête avec vous nous
travaillons sur des scénarios qui sont
différents c'est ma responsabilité de
ministre des finances
personne n'a de certitude dans ma
responsabilité de mise des finances dont
la première responsabilité de garantir
que il y aura financièrement ce qu'il
faut pour soutenir les français les
salariés et les entreprises comme l'a
souhaité le présent la république c'est
d'étudier plusieurs options
il ya au moins trois grandes options et
trois grands scénarios le premier c'est
celui où la situation sanitaire ne nous
oblige pas à prendre des mesures
sanitaires complémentaires
c'est le scénario du statu quo nous
arrivons à traverser cette période sans
mesures de restrictions sanitaires
supplémentaires qui pèsent sur
l'économie
dans ce cas là nous avons comme vous
l'avez voter comme je voulais proposer
une croissance qui pourrait atteindre 6%
en 2021 et une vraie capacité de rebond
de l'économie française soyons clairs ce
scénario aujourd'hui n'est plus le plus
probable et il s'éloigne
à mesure que la situation sanitaire
reste préoccupante
le deuxième scénario c'est celui où la
situation sanitaire nous obligerait à
prendre de nouvelles mesures de
restrictions sanitaires qui pèseront
nécessairement sur les co2 et en
fonction de la dureté des mesures qui
sont prises
l'impact sur l'économie est plus fort
dans ce cas là bien entendu nous aurons
une croissance qui ne pourra pas
atteindre les 6% en 2021 regardez ce qui
se passe dans les autres pays européens
ce que je crois qu'il faut aussi voir
que c'est la situation de tous les pays
européens sans exception
l'allemagne a déjà indiqué que sa
croissance serait sans doute très
inférieur à ce qui avait été annoncé on
parle de chiffres de l'ordre de 3%
donc on est très en dessous de ce qui
avait été lancée parce que l'allemagne a
décidé sous l'autorité de la chancelière
angela merkel de mesures de confinement
strict est longue et l'impact sur les
finances publiques comme sa croissance
est évidemment très fort et puis il ya
un troisième scénario dont j'ose espérer
que c'est un pur scénario et que c' est
pour le moment est quelque chose qui n'a
pas lieu de se produire c'est celui où à
nouveau une nouvelle forme de virus
arriverait au milieu de l'année et nous
obligerait à rester dans des conditions
sanitaires difficiles jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2021
je leur dis ce n'est pas le scénario le
plus probable mais c'est ma
responsabilité aujourd'hui d'étudier
l'intégralité des scénarios leur impact
sur les finances publiques et leur
impact sur la croissance française
dans tous les cas de figure quel que
soit le scénario qui se présentera je le
redis les mesures de soutien économiques
resteront à disposition des salariés et
des entreprises
et c'est bien parce que je veux me
préparer à tous les cas de figure que je
présente en toute transparence
l'intégralité des scénarios sur lesquels
nous travaillons avec mes équipes
pour moi le scénario de référence reste
celui d'une amélioration de la situation
au milieu de l'année 2000 21 qui
permettra un rebond puissant de
l'économie française dans la dernière
partie de l'économie 2021 c'est à dire
dans la fin du troisième et le quatrième
trimestre 2001 21 c'est mon scénario de
référence une fois encore il est soumis
aux aléas sanitaires
mais l'économie française a montré une
chose au cours des derniers mois quand
les mesures de restrictions sanitaires
sont levés l'économie française rebondit
fortement parce que les fondamentaux
d'économie français sont sains je veux
leur dire avec beaucoup de fermeté sur
la conversion des prêts garantis par
l'état en subventions peut-être
reprendre plus globalement cette
question des prêts garantis par l'état
parce que derrière il ya la question du
financement de notre économie
je redis que nous adaptons les
dispositifs à la réalité de la situation
économique nous ne sommes pas droits
dans nos bottes à vous dire on a voté
quelque chose ça ne bouge pas d'un
millimètre non il faut savoir s'adapter
à la réalité des situations économiques
s'il y a des entreprises qui sont en
très grande difficulté alors même
qu'elle aurait des perspectives de
redressement un peu plus lointaine
moi je n'exclus pas que nous puissions
avec la commission européenne et en
accord les qu'elle étudie pour ces
entreprises les plus en difficulté s'il
y a des perspectives de redressement je
suis prudent parce qu'il s'agit pas que
ça devienne la règle mais qu'on puisse
progamme par cas avec l'accord de la
commission européenne
transformer certains prêts garantis par
l'état en subventions en tout cas je
trouve que cela mérite d'être étudié je
dis bien au cas par cas pour certains
secteurs quand il ya des capacités de
redressement qui peuvent se présenter
c'est une option qui mérite d'être
étudiée que nous présenterons donc à la
commission européenne
de la même façon que j'ai indiqué que
pour le secteur de l'aéronautique avoir
un étalement un peu plus important parce
que les sommes empruntées sont
importantes et que le transport aérien
ne serait ce pas est une option que nous
deux
aussi étudié pour toutes les autres
entreprises je rappelle que nous avons
obtenus a différé de remboursement du
capital de un an supplémentaire et des
taux d'intérêt particulièrement
attractif enfin toujours sur cette
question de trésorerie je veux insister
sur un point très important il faut
soutenir la capacité d'investissement
des entreprises c'est un des enjeux
stratégiques de la reprise de la relance
et donc de la création d'emplois je
présenterai dans les jours qui viennent
les éléments des prêts participatifs qui
nous permettrons d'octroyer aux
entreprises qui veulent investir des
quasi fonds propres dans des conditions
financières qui sont les plus
avantageuses possible et avec a différé
de remboursement de 4 ans donc des prêts
participatifs qui va quasi fonds propres
qui ne pèse pas sur l'endettement des
entreprises et dont le remboursement ne
se commet ce que quatre années après
avoir obtenu ces prêts
c'est une façon de répondre aux besoins
d'investissement des entreprises
s'agissant des frais fixes nous avons
mis en place c'est une remarque qui
avait été fait effectivement par
beaucoup de sénateurs
nous avons mis en place un premier
dispositif en novembre était un crédit
d'impôt permettant de rembourser la
moitié des frais de loyer qui sont les
principales charges fixes qui pèsent
aujourd'hui sur les entreprises qui ne
sont pas ouvertes ou qui fonctionne au
ralenti le ce dispositif ne peut pas
être inscrit dans la durée parce
qu'après et vous transférer la charge
des entreprises sur les bailleurs et
dans le fond c'est pas la solution
idéale sur le long terme
c'est pour cela que nous avons prévu la
possibilité de prendre jusqu'à 70 % des
charges fixes en compte dans le soutien
de l'état en plus de l'aide du fonds de
solidarité
chaque entreprise dès lors qu'elle a un
minimum de chiffre d'affaires de 1
million d'euros qui appartient au
secteur touché le plus par la crise
l'hôtellerie les cafés restauration le
tourisme peu de vent d une couverture
jusqu'à 70% de ses charges fixes dans un
plafond de 3 millions d'euros que nous
sommes en train de négocier avec la
commission européenne car je n'exclus
pas il faut encore si la crise dure que
ce plafond dessus
fils passe un plafond qui court de
janvier à juin 2021
il peut arriver par exemple pour des
chaînes hôtelières pour des chaînes de
restauration que ce plafond de 3
millions d'euros ne soit pas suffisant
donc nous sommes en train d'étudier avec
la commission européenne la possibilité
de le relever
vous voyez avec tous les exemples que je
vous donne que nous gardons les mêmes
dispositifs et je le redis nous ne
cessons de les compléter de les adapter
pour qu'il réponde le mieux possible à
la situation des entreprises sur le
terrain
s'agissant du plan de relance en 2020 et
de sa sous consommation
je le redis nous avons toujours dit que
nous ferions 10% du plan de relance en
2020 c'est à dire 10 milliards d'euros
ils sont faibles 6 très précisément
s'agissant des collectivités locales il
y à un moindre décaissements en 2020
pour une raison très simple c'est qu'il
ya une moindre baisse des recettes
exactement comme pour l'état nous avons
eu la bonne surprise d'avoir une moindre
baisse des recettes simplement parce
qu'il ya eu un fort rebond est donc la
tva est bien rentré lire est mieux
rentré prévu parce que nous avons bien
amorti le choc sur le pouvoir d'achat
des ménages
eliès est également mieux rentrés que
prévu parce que l'impact sur l'économie
a été moindre que ce que nous avions
prévu
s'agissant de la prime à la conversion
je vous confirme qu'effectivement des
chiffres sont un peu inférieures à ce
que nous avions prévu mais le bonus
écologique fonctionne bien et les
résultats sont là
nous avons multiplié par trois les
ventes de véhicules électriques en 2020
en part de marché des véhicules
électriques c'était un peu moins avec 2
9 % du marché
cela a bondi à 6 % et la tendance reste
la même
raison de plus je le dis au passage pour
que nous réussissions impérativement le
déploiement de 100000 bornes électriques
en 2021 sur les réseaux routiers
français parce que rien ne serait pire
que d'avoir vendu des véhicules
électriques pour français et qui ne
trouve pas des bornes de recharge sur
les routes
et croyez moi il ya un certain nombre
d'obstacles techniques a levé et je mets
toute ma détermination et tout mon
engagement
faire en sorte que nous arrivions à
déployer ses cent mille bornes
électriques en 2021
enfin dernier point sur l'association
des collectivités locales moi je redis
que nous travaillons très bien avec les
régions que nous voulons continuer à
travailler main dans la main avec la
région sur le déploiement du plan de
relance et que toutes les aides
complémentaires sont évidemment toujours
les bienvenus merci nous avons dix
inscrits donc nous allons faire en 2 x 5
si vous voulez bien me suis mise donc
nous démarrons avec roger karoutchi
puis sébastien meurant monsieur le
président je me dis ça je fais pas être
très long une observation et de
questions l'observation elle reprend
celle du rapporteur général
je me souviens je crois que c'était en
juin dernier où on nous disait baffe pas
de problème
après la crise sanitaire en 2021 rebond
de 9% du pib pas de souci et cgt il faut
qu'on bria que je suis j'étais déjà sur
le thème ou là vous allez un peu vite
avec le virus n'a pas l'air d'avoir dit
son dernier mot celui-là est est ce que
vous n'avez pas le sentiment qu'il
faudrait peut-être être plus plus
modérés sur les possibilités presque le
virus n'a pas disparu et sincèrement je
vous entends le seul ministre et si je
puis me permettre je prie pour que vous
ayez raison mais malheureusement le
virus est insensible la prière et si
j'ai bien compris si j'ai bien compris
pour le moment les vaccins ou les
laboratoires d'isola ça marche sur le
variant angles et sud africaines comme
par hasard ils prennent aucun engagement
sur le variant brésiliens ont sur la
grogne en californien ce qui veut dire
que on a le sentiment parce que certains
nous disent vous en avez pour des années
d'autres nous disent oh là il faudra
changer les vaccins à la fin de l'année
bref
franchement je crains que le que le le
stop and go ne soit pas finie en 2021
par conséquent est-ce que sans nous le
dire mais ce que bercy travaille quand
même sur des modèles des schémas à long
terme ou quand je dis à long terme sur
les trois quatre ans qui viennent qui
sont un peu moins optimiste que
simplement allez ça va être vite fait on
est tous vaccinés fin août et vous allez
voir on est tous au boulot est ce que
quand même il n'y a pas des choses plus
plus risquées sur la fin de l'année et
l'année 2022 ensuite deux questions
rapides
monsieur le président je m'y étais
engagé premier point on apprend que sur
l'année 2020 malgré les aides et
l'action énergique de votre ministère
pour soutenir l'activité
on a eu sept et demi pour cent de
chômeurs supplémentaires
est-ce que sur 2021 vous avez une
perspective où vous avez eu une idée de
ce que pourrait être avec malgré tout
les faillites d'entreprises et les
difficultés le nombre de chômeurs à la
fin de l'année et deuxième question le
l'activité partielle a coûté 27
milliards d'euros en 2020 c'était un peu
plus que ce qui était prévu en tout cas
initialement
est-ce qu'on a une idée de ce que
pourrait être le coût de l'activité
partielle en 2021
merci pour cette excellente note
d'optimisme que nous apprécions toujours
avec roger karoutchi
si sébastien meurant le veut bien je
vais si l'année d'accord donner la
parole albéric de montgolfier qui doit
s'en aller et qui va s'excuser auprès du
ministre parce qu'il écoutera la réponse
après sa mort parce que je reçois le
présent de la mf hors la loi qui doit
concerner persie du sur le courtage qui
vit en commission la semaine prochaine
donc il faut il faut avancer sur ce le
rapport de cette loi sur le courtage
donc c'est une bonne raison voilà donc
le président de la mef est arrivé
monsieur mais une seule question puisque
le soutien et massif je crois que nous
l'avons d'ailleurs à prouver leur
apportant général l'a rappelé à
l'occasion notamment des pfr que nous
avons amendé et au final approuvé et on
ne conteste pas une question simplement
concernant le pg vous avez souligné
qu'il n'y a jamais eu aussi peu de
faillite c'est vrai est ce que
finalement c'est pas malheureusement un
petit peu pour avoir une année 2021
voire 2022 qui serait pire notamment
avec des entreprises qui auraient
souscrit au pge
alors qu'en temps normal elle serait
finalement peu viable et elles ont
bénéficié de ces mesures de trésorerie
très concrètement est ce que vous ne
craignez pas un pourcentage considérable
d'entreprises qui ne pourraient pas
rembourser
on a de fait peut-être un peu
artificiellement m'amener une trésorerie
ou à des entreprises qui en temps normal
aurait été en difficulté et le fait
qu'on ait aussi peu de faillite c'est
finalement peut-être pas si rassurant
que ça allait donc la raison craignez
vous pas qu'il y ait des entreprises
qu'ils aient eu un effet d'aubaine en se
disant je prends le pge parce que c'est
un prêt qui n'a pas de garantie pas de
caution la part de l'entreprise
c'est finalement une mesure de
trésorerie relativement simple et on
peut s'en féliciter je crois que nous
avons tous souhaité collectivement pizol
le plus simple possible
keven une nécessité due à l'urgence mais
est ce que finalement il n'y a pas ce
risque d'avoir à défaut d'avoir une
années 2020
ils soient bonnes des années suivantes
qui rélève finalement un nombre défiance
plus importante et donc je vais écouter
prix en ms pour papa et la ppl nous nous
retrouverons prochainement sur le
courtage un sujet absolument
passionnante merci monsieur merci el
merrikh sébastien meurant ont donc merci
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
une fête de la situation sanitaire
les perspectives dans cette situation
particulière soit difficile à envisager
peut le comprendre bien sûr d'ailleurs
lorsque la situation est normale à
l'avenir est toujours incertain
par contre là où là une problème sur la
cohérence la situation sanitaire
elle est mondiale différents degrés et
la réaction des états j'ai simplement
s'intéresser à l'europe elle est
différente
quand vous parlez de l'allemagne là qui
prend aujourd'hui des mesures
extrêmement dures sur l'année 2020 la
chute du pig babe et va être moitié
moindre que chez nous et la situation de
départ est évidemment très différente
donc à l'arrivée lorsque on se félicite
de pouvoir s'endetter
peuchère bien sûr mais la crise elle
vient elle les idents pas prévu elles
elles arrivent sans prévenir jeudi et
les taux d'intérêt pourraient revenir et
de ne serait-ce que augmenté de quelques
points et nous mettre dans une situation
intenable
on ne leur pas de ne pas faire de de la
dette met pas et ne va pas pouvoir faire
date mais voilà de devoir rembourser et
sur cette situation des sanitaires dans
les hémicycles
nous sommes quelques centaines et on
voit pas comment
le monde de la culture on n'a pas pu
continuer à fonctionner selon certaines
situations on voit dans certains pays
qui a maintenu des stations de ski
ouvertes et que mathilde des restaurants
de ski au vert et nous on a choisi de
confiner de fermer et ça c'est un choix
politique c'est une décision qui va
entraîner la disparation malgré tous les
efforts que vous que l'état fait est là
on ne vous soutenu dans cette démarche
parce que c'est une décision qui a été
radical de fermeture peu importe ce
qu'ils ont fait les efforts de prendre
les mesures sanitaires de respecter et
d'autres pays n'ont pas fait choix là
donc à l'arrivée il y aura des écarts et
là dans un département sur des questions
une question posée sur le nos hôpitaux
dans mon département et les hôpitaux qui
sont en train d'être continue à être
fermé est là la réponse de l'état par
rapport à ce que nous vivons paraît
incompréhensible de la part des locaux
et de la part des personnels qui
travaillent et aider des malades et moi
sur les entreprises hors norme dans les
capitales des compétences hors norme
je termine dans mon département j'ai une
entreprise petites entreprises
stratégiques reconnu par l'état comme
stratégiques qui a des contrats signés
avec l'état mais du fait de
l'interdiction de voyager là et
désespéré va mettre la clé sous la porte
et je suis ravi de conseil est là et je
vais m'entretenir vous permettez avec
vos collaborateurs
parce que là qui a les brevets ouais
entreprises stratégiques
c'était contrat signé par l'état et qui
là est au bord de la faillite
hélas ses compétences hors norme nous
avons dans un pub créatif et ça serait
vraiment dommage de les laisser partir à
l'étranger ou de les voir mettre la clé
sous la porte donc si elle est mesure
pour ce genre de petites structures qui
sont passés pour l'instant à travers les
mailles du filet de soutien merci merci
sébastien pascal savoldelli
merci monsieur le ministre mes collègues
ayant dit tous les trois qu'il use of
qu'ils avaient soutenu au plan de
relance je veux sujet de dire que moi je
n'ai pas fait ou le savez monsieur le
ministre
voilà cela étant dit je vais procès avec
le même plan que une observation et des
questions une observation je vous avoue
que je ne suis pas un homme qui fait la
politique et les petites phrases tout ça
fait de la politique
j'ai regardé ce qu'on était tous nos
débats depuis une loi de finances auquel
j'ai participé 2017 2018 2019
nous avions une dette dangereuse
alarmante se posait la question de la
solvabilité d'ailleurs aussi bien la
dette publique que la dette privée
aujourd'hui on a une dette faramineuse
et là elle devient solvables
remboursables il ya là quand même du
trouble donc on se posait la question de
l'opinion des françaises et des français
je suis aussi dans le trouble alors je
me suis dit comme j'ai vu qu'ils avaient
posées de l'élection législative
partielle je me dis il ya quelque chose
d'autre
donc puisque là il ya quand même un
retournement de certitude celle istres
voilà si je peux me permettre cette
observation est en fait je voudrais
savoir si si parlons au conditionnel on
était dans une situation de confinement
quels sont à votre avis les activités
économiques essentielles à votre avis
avec les retours que vous avez des
différents acteurs économiques
est ce que vous avez présenté ma
deuxième question c'est dans quel
domaine vous envisagez un plan de
réindustrialisation
vous avez évoqué l'hydrogène vous avez
évoqué le cantique moi je vous donne un
avis mais parce que c'est aussi un débat
je pense qu'il faut prendre les
questions de la santé
là je vous donne une autre piste
l'électronique et puis une troisième est
pas par nostalgie mais je pense qu'il ya
un enjeu et que le textile avec la
reconversion du coton on aurait tout
intérêt ce que la france retrouve sa
place dans ce domaine là donc qu'est ce
que vous envisagez avec quels moyens
et puis la troisième chose je vous
remercie parce que je trouve que
d'ailleurs globalement
le trouve que ce gouvernement répond
assez vite aux questions des
parlementaires
on peut ne pas partager totalement la
réponse mais au moins il ya un respect
mois et répondu sur thales vous avez
évoqué l'aéronautique
j'étais inquiet il ya quand même mille
suppressions de postes j'ai un site à
rungis et sur lequel vous m'avez répondu
et à la fin de votre courrier monsieur
le ministre vous revenez sur la question
du versement des des acomptes sur les
dividendes et vous réméré speak et à
juste titre et je la partage votre
position sur le fait qu' il vous paraît
pas en porte un que les entreprises qui
sont durement touchés par la crise
reprennent dès à présent le versement
d'acompte sur dividende
je vais pas vous demander évidemment
nominativement qu'il a faits qui l'a pas
fait mais quand même quel est votre
appréciation
quelle a été l'attitude des grandes
entreprises et l'attitude en termes de
versement des acomptes des dividendes je
vous dis ça parce que dans le choc ya
dans l'opinion française et c'est pas
une question de bouche droit il ya
énormément de français et françaises qui
sont extrêmement choqués par ces
questions voilà merci merci pascal
thiery cozic puis sophie dany brillant
merci le ainsi monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre également les plus
près du micro peut être un peu plus près
c'est mieux la wii
tout à l'heure vous avez vous avez fait
état de votre souhait de devoir une
bonne exécution du plan de relance
donc je souhaite intervenir sur ce sujet
globalement le plan de relance
mobilisent d'importants moyens qui
répond notamment à l'impératif de
transformation et le moderne et de
modernisation du tissu productif à
horizon 2030
néanmoins me semble-t-il
ils négligent l'enjeu de relance à court
terme de l'économie française et
notamment les crédits de la mission plan
de relance portent majoritairement sur
des actions à horizon 2022 2023
voire plus lointaines à rebours de
l'impératif de relance rapide sur les 22
millions d'euros crédit annoncée pour
2021 se confondent en réalité des
mesures d'urgence les mesures de long
terme et et des musées et des mesures de
pardon des mesures d'urgence des mesures
de long terme et des mesures de relance
le stimulus budgétaires de court terme
est donc plus faible qu'annoncé et qu'il
n'est nécessaire
mais je crois que ce n'est pas le plus
gros écueil tel qui est tel qu'on peut
le voir aujourd'hui et notamment dans
les territoires
je constate tout de même que le plan de
relance aujourd'hui est calibré vous
l'avez évoqué notamment avec les régions
et calibré à destination des grosses
collectivités qui ont l'arsenal
administratifs nécessaires pour pouvoir
traiter les dossiers avec avec une vraie
célérité en revanche pour les petites
communes et on sait que pendant cette
crise sanitaire elles ont été le maillon
important dans dans la gestion de la
crise
j'ai aujourd'hui de vrais retours sur la
difficulté à monter les dossiers et
notamment ses petites communes ont une
vraie volonté de s'engager dans le
processus mais n'y arrive que trop peu
faute d'ingénierie et d'accompagnement
suffisant et également sur des délais
extrêmement courts donc ma question est
simple c'est comment aujourd'hui vous
pourrez vous pouvez enfin l'étape peut
rassurer nos petites communes sur la
faculté aller à mettre tous les moyens
d'ingénierie possible pour les
accompagner dans les montages de
dossiers si nécessaire pour déployer ce
plan de relance merci thierry sophie
taillé pour lyon merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous avez
évoqué vos priorités et évidemment par
rapport à la gestion de cette crise tant
au niveau des plans d'urgence qu'au
niveau du plan de relance
nous nous avons soutenu un certain
nombre de dispositifs le chômage partiel
le fonds de solidarité les prêts
garantis par l'état et je vous rejoins
également sur le fait qu'il faille
décaissés au plus vite s'agissant du
plan de relance mais pour nous il ya
aussi d'autres priorités et votre action
est un autre sens déséquilibrée entre
d'une part cette volonté d'aider et de
soutenir l'économie pour lui permettre
son rebond ultérieur et d'autre part la
transition écologique et la lutte contre
la pauvreté et les
le véritable politique pour éviter un
approfondissement des inégalités qu'on
observe par ailleurs c'est un
déséquilibre qui nous semblent majeur
aujourd'hui l'épargné très importante
d'un côté et on observe une
paupérisation extrême de l'autre alors
vous appeler ce que cette épargne des
français servent à l'investissement
pourquoi pas s'il est productif surtout
si les verts mais certainement pas je
crois ce ne seraient pas de bonne
politique s'il aboutit à faire grimper
les prix de l'immobilier vous appelait
aussi à la consommation de cette épargne
mais je crains bien que les dépenses des
indes ne fasse pas le
alors on n'aime pas dire et le bonheur
mais en tout cas là la situation digne
des autres parce qu'on en attendant ce
sont des familles qui sont quand même en
situation de de tomber dans la dans la
pauvreté et vous dit s'il ya des besoins
nous irons nous serons là et c'est je
crois que les besoins sont vraiment
extrêmement prégnant et que les mesures
qui ont été prises étaient trop faible
et souvent de très très très court terme
pour les familles les plus en difficulté
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que d'autres d'autres mesures
complémentaires sont absolument
indispensables
je pense notamment aux
micro-entrepreneurs là qui vont être
touchés par l'arrêt des aides du fonds
de fonds de solidarité
lorsqu'ils ne sont pas tout à fait
directement un passionné sur les
activités qui sont fermées
administrativement et on a là beaucoup
de gens qui vont encore être davantage
impacté est davantage mis en grande
difficulté
je pense aussi dans le plan de relance
au fameux 1% qui devrait être fléché
dans les quartiers prioritaires
politique de la ville c'est un
engagement du premier ministre suite à
l'appel des maires or dans les comités
départementaux ce qui nous est dit qu en
nous posant la question c'est que il
n'ya pas de fléchage donc évidemment il
y aura une attention particulière sur
les projets qui seraient relatifs à ces
quartiers mais bon on n'est pas dans une
situation où on va voir véritablement un
fléchage
alors je partage le fait qu'il faut
décaisser il faut aller au projet je
dirais
qu'il faut aller aux projets qui sont
prêts pour ce qui concerne les semaines
et les mois qui viennent mais il faut
aussi s'attacher à faire en sorte que
ces crédits puissent être répartie et
notamment les crédits de la dessine mais
d'autres crédits de manière à ne pas
aggraver les inégalités
je je je terminerais très rapidement sur
la question de la dette vous dites nous
la rembourseront eynulla rembourseront
notamment par une baisse des dépenses
publiques et notamment des réformes
structurelles telles que les retraites
vous imaginez bien que ce n'est pas la
philosophie qui est la mienne mais mais
mais je je souhaite vous interroger sur
cet agenda
on a aujourd'hui un accord européen d'où
nous allons débattre la semaine
prochaine en séance
avec comme indication un engagement des
pays à faire des réformes structurelles
est ce que la réforme des retraites a
été abordé et 2e deuxièmement n'y at il
pas aujourd'hui d'autre voie explorée
notamment fiscales qui garantirait
davantage de justice fiscale
je pense à la proposition au projet de
loi que nous avions voté ici même sur la
taxe gars femmes
il ya aujourd'hui des changements
majeurs au niveau international est-ce
que nous allons pouvoir enfin aboutir je
sais que c'est un dossier que vous avez
beaucoup suivi pour faire en sorte que
les les multinationales de ce type
puisse être véritablement contributive
hauteur des besoins de nos sociétés
merci vu le temps qu'il nous reste
monsieur le ministre compte tenu de
votre emploi du temps je vous propose
finalement de prendre l'ensemble des
questions est ce toi et d'avoir une
vision collective sur les réponses
apportées vous laissant le soin de les
classer par grands thèmes si vous voulez
bien allons nous poursuivons avec michel
canévet merci monsieur le président
messieurs mes chers collègues
effectivement la réponse du gouvernement
était massive comme cela a été dit
la traitement de cette crise il faut
s'en féliciter il faudra simplement que
nous prenions bien grand sens de
diffuser le message que l'argent n'est
pas facile auprès du grand public qui
vont les milliards qui pleuvent ici et
on doit faire comprendre qu'après cette
crise et bien il y aura des réformes
structurelles à poursuivre à mener et
bien je comprends que cela appellera
aussi des efforts de la part de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens parce que
on ne peut pas continuer à dépenser
beaucoup plus pour ne touchant recettes
alors dans cette crise il ya encore
quelques éléments difficiles toute la
horde a évoqué l'aéronautique
il y à aussi bien sûr et vous le savez
autant que les normands la question du
trafic maritime du trafic de passagers
maritimes des compagnies maritimes ou
l'eurostar d'ailleurs qui est en
difficulté aussi qu'ils attendent que
les conditions de compétitivité pour
leur avenir soit réunie et n'importe que
l'on puisse leur donner des assurances
grotte retour à ces conditions de
compétitivité pour ma part je plaide
pour un remboursement des de la part des
charges salariales de façon à leur
donner cette productivité sur le long
terme mais froid qu'il sera important
qu'il y ait des réponses qui ne reçoit
effectivement donné sur la dette vous
avez évoqué mais seul ministre les
conditions dans lesquelles la france
emprunte là maintenant je suppose que ce
sont des emprunts à taux variable donc
il faudra là aussi que nous serons
vigilants parce que la charge des
intérêts de la dette pourrait augmenter
si la situation était moins favorable
qu'elle ne le sont maintenant les
intérêts de la dette
et puis dernier point sur les filières
de valeur qu'il le faut relancer dans
notre pays
vous en avez cité un certain nombre
j'aime beaucoup ma part la conviction
qu'il faut aussi mais c'est sans doute à
l'échelle européenne que de soyons
beaucoup plus allons sur les questions
numériques pour qu'il y ait quelques
champions numérique en europe est assez
à ce titre la commande d'état est
importante pour justement permettre à
des acteurs numériques d'émerger donc il
faut que l'on soit très vigilant sur ce
sujet de la commande d'état mais c'est
un secteur qui est essentielle elle va
bien avec la valorisation économique des
gars femmes et autres acteurs chinois
il est important que l'europe aussi s
est champion en la matière est que nous
ne soyons pas totalement dépendant des
puissances étrangères pour ce qui
concerne le recours au numérique
merci michel poursuivre avec rémi féraud
puis charles bonnet merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre on a qu'à
ce stade il faut être bref toujours est
vous poser deux questions sur chacun
finalement des sujets dont on parle qui
sont très différents à l'afp
le plan d'urgence et un plan
d'investissements d'avenir et c'est vrai
qu'on jongle entre les concepts et pour
nous parlementaires ce n'est pas non
plus toujours évident d'ailleurs de
ligne de des différentes missions
budgétaires et de plf en plfr de crédits
consommés en crédit plutôt reportée il
est assez difficile d'avoir pour notre
part une lecture claire des choses y
compris parce que la situation est
évolutive et parce qu'aussi leur
présentation volontariste est aussi
parfois assez mélangé
j'ai d'ailleurs au ciel pas pourrait pas
répondre précisément mais fo espère
aussi que le prochain plfr soit
l'occasion de pouvoir avoir aussi un
état des lieux de la situation des
actions engagées de celles qui sont
nécessaires
moi j'aurai deux questions l'une sur le
plan d'urgence dont nous contestons pas
la légitimité ni même l'importance mais
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent qu'il
y a des éléments qui manque c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'a montré notre
discussion je crois au sénat sur la
mission plan de relance est ce que
justement certain nombre de ces éléments
que nous avions essayé d'introduire
voter puis retiré ne manquent pas à
votre avis aujourd'hui je parle même pas
des outre-mer ou de la culture
mais pour les jeunes et est ce que
d'ailleurs ces crédits d'urgence ne
pourraient pas venir aussi alimenter la
consommation dont nous avons absolument
besoin puisque on voit qu'il ya d'un
côté beaucoup d' épargne mais d'un autre
côté des gens dont la paupérisation
entraîne aussi une sous consommation qui
pourrait alimenter la relance sur le
plan d'investissements d'avenir une
question qui est un peu dans la suite de
ce que disait pascal savoldelli quelle
est la méthode
comment se font les choix de secteurs
quel est le rôle du haut commissaire au
plan
comment se définit la feuille de route
comment se font les choix par rapport à
des investissements d'avenir qui sont en
effet tout à fait essentiel pour la
nation sophie rémy charles bonnet suivi
de stéphane total oui merci monsieur le
président messieurs milices merci pour
votre exposé très pédagogique qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs dans dans vos
mémoires outre le style est très élégant
au fait monsieur l'ogc nice
une remarque il ne remarque est une
question alors la première première
remarque elle tient tôt au devoir de
vérité qu'à évoquer de remporter en
général et qui provoquent les troubles
ne d'autres familles pascal savoldelli
et les angoisses philosophique de même
madame tailler pas lyon et c'est donc où
on sait pertinemment que finalement nous
bénéficions de trait bretons parce que
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
le gouverneur de la banque de france
safran la france n'a jamais failli à sa
parole pour rembourser sa dette mais
aussi parce que il ya des gens qui
pensent que nous allons à la foire bien
sûr réindustrialiser notre pays c'est
l'aspect positif très positif des choses
comme tu l'as vos clics
mais aussi effectuer des réformes qu'il
faut et simplement le petit doute que
j'ai c'est un peu c'est quand même
quelque chose qu'il faut faire partager
le plus rapidement possible sinon on ira
vers de cruelles désillusions
voilà c'est le prof c'était ma remarque
le deuxième point concerne l'aide au aux
entreprises
vous avez évoqué la simplicité des
mesures que et leur maintien aussi
longtemps qu'il le faut effectivement je
vous suis là dessus mais pour avoir
discuté que de nombreux chefs
d'entreprises qui sont pas relax helmand
très très angoissée alors qu'ils ont
quand même un parapluie qui est quand
même assez bien ouverts généralement ces
mesures portent sur des garanties de
chiffre d'affaires et des choses comme
ça et comme l'a évoqué le rapporteur
général
nous savons qu'al au juge de paix c'est
quand même le compte d'exploitation
alors vous avez tout à l'heure
développer effectivement la possibilité
de
de prêts participatifs d'être
supplémentaire lorsqu'il ya des
capacités de redressement mais je pense
qu'il y aura toute une frange
d'entreprise qui qui aura des problèmes
d'exploitation qui sera pas forcément
dans les seuils que vous souhaitez et je
pense qu'il serait important que vous
puissiez leur donner des garanties ou
alors est-ce que vous excluez totalement
de rentrer dans ces éléments de grandes
exploitations
merci stephen stéphane total donc suivi
des philippe dallier
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre
j'essayais de me borner à deux aspects
en étant pragmatique et et avec le souci
de de la confiance en fait puisque je
crois que c'est ça qui est qui est
essentiel donc à la fois pour décaisser
pour investir donc premier premier point
sur toute la partie qui concerne la
protection
je voulais juste insister sur quelques
remarques de terrain est très
pragmatique sur ce prix il est coutume
d'appeler les trous dans la raquette qui
peuvent encore exister et sur lequel
effectivement il ya eu de nombreux
ajustements mais je crois que le
dialogue est encore nécessaire sur des
aspects sur les effets de seuil sur
l'amendé filière aussi parfois où il ya
quelques quelques oublis parce que les
activités sont pas directement concernés
mais elles sont impactées de fait sur la
réalité aussi saisonnière
je pense en particulier au secteur de la
montagne dans l'appréciation ne peut pas
se faire sur quelques mois mais sur
l'année même si 95% du chiffre
d'affaires est réalisé sur trois mois et
puis aussi sur les périodes de référence
puisque on était sur des périodes de
référence qui était de -1 et la
maintenant en 2021 le moins jeunes
n'aura plus beaucoup de valeur donc sur
toute cette partie de la protection
peut-être des ajustements et donc un
dialogue avec les remontées de terrain
deuxième volet sur la sur la relance
donc effectivement je reviendrai pas sur
les aspects de territorialisation qui me
semble bien sûr essentielle mais aussi
sur la manière dont cette relance aller
articulé justement entre le territoire
et le central genre j'en veux pour
preuve les le premier appel à projets
sur la résilience qui pour une
entreprise de mon département qui
travaille justement dans le secteur de
la santé et sur les thérapies par le
microbiote donc qui est un secteur
d'avenir et qui avait été très
encouragée et qui au final ne s'est pas
vu retenues dans cet appel à projets
alors que c'est à la fois des
investissements d'avenir des créations
d'emplois est donc sacré d
incompréhension alors que par ailleurs
l'objectif c'est de consommer d'engager
des crédits et d'investir puisque leur
unité sur un programme d'investissements
conséquents et de même dans les dents
les contrats dans les plans de relance
qui sont aujourd'hui signé entre l'état
et les régions
on s'aperçoit j'ai vu celui qui avait
été signé dans la région auvergne
rhône-alpes connais beaucoup sur des
gros seins france investissement
structurant avec peut-être un regard sur
les territoires qui n'est pas
suffisamment fins et j'espère que les cp
verts vont pouvoir corriger corriger
cela voilà jour merci merci stéphane
philippe dallier ministre comme le
rapporteur général
je veux saluer votre volontarisme et
votre confiance dans la capacité de ce
pays à rebondir
effectivement très fortement même si ce
que vous nous aviez dit il ya quelques
mois à saillir espérer le retour à
l'entée crise en 2022 semble
effectivement s'éloigner un peu
ceci étant dit je vous ai trouvé trop
rassurant sur la bête
traoré en tous les cas tout à l'heure
parce que la situation est quand même
extrêmement difficile on peut se
féliciter france trésor est placé 7
milliards à 50 ans à un taux
relativement bas
c'est très bien mais il me semble avoir
lu ce week-end un article dans un
hebdomadaire où effectivement il était
fait état d'un certain nombre
d'angoissés france trésor à l'idée quand
même d'avoir à placer pas loin de 300
milliards aux rennais ce sont des sommes
que nous n'avons
jamais atteint alors d'un côté on a un
certain nombre de politiques qui disent
la dette c'est pas grave on la
remboursera pas et cetera vous inquiétez
pas de local discours qui dit mais
regardez les taux sont extrêmement bas
et ça va durer donc finalement comment
convaincre les français qui va falloir
faire ces réformes structurelles après
on verra comment répartir l'effort mais
faire les efforts et les faits
relativement vite
le gouverneur de la banque de france
nous disait ce matin qu'il espérait
qu'en dix ans en mai 10h c'est très long
nous reviendrions de 120% du pub à 100%
dix ans c'est l'écart qui nous sépare de
la dernière crise de la crise actuelle
peut se passer énormément de choses
encore j'ai trop et monsieur le ministre
votre discours peut-être trop trop
rassurant sur le nôtre difficulté a
modélisé les effets de la crise on l'a
vu avec la l'exercice 2001 bon sort avec
45 milliards de moins sur l'exécution
tant mieux pour autant ça démontre la
difficulté à mobiliser et j'avais
interrogé olivier dussopt aps la semaine
dernière sur les prévisions faites pour
l'année 2000 21 est la suivante il m'a
pas vraiment répondu le gouverneur de la
banque de france ce matin nous a dit
effectivement que lui il estimait le
taux de chute des entreprises
bénéficiant d'un peugeot de 4 à 6%
ce que vous pensez que moi ça me semble
enfin comme ça c'est ça me semble faible
j'espère que qu'il a raison qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
merci philippe vincent subway
et jean michel arnaud et vacins se voir
aura donc l'occasion cet après-midi de
poser sa question
1 ce matin j'étais un peu plus peu trop
tard merci monsieur présent c'était
compliqué ce matin en effet oui monsieur
le ministre de questions la première
c'est sur le pg les entreprises et tpe
ont souscrit des pga à hauteur de 25 %
de leur chiffre d'affaires hors elles
ont un seuil de rentabilité qui tourne
autour de 3 à 4% et elles devront
rembourser en quatre ans
je n'arrive pas à comprendre la règle de
calcul si vous pouviez m'éclaircir sur
ce sujet là le deuxième point sur la
dette j'ai alors je poursuis un peu ce
que philippe dallier viennent de vous
poser comme questions sur la dette
quand nous avions une croissance en
rythme normal 1,5 pour cent des étions
incapables de rembourser le capital
et là vous nous dites qu'avec la
croissance
on va leur rembourser mais est-ce que
vous tabler sur une croissance de 3%
terraine pendant 30 ans puisqu'il ya
aussi la dette européenne qui viendra
s'ajouter en plus pour rembourser
voila voila ma question sur le sur la
dette
merci toujours une question très
optimiste
jean-louis non mais jean michel arnaud
une petite note positive et s'il vous
plaît pour terminer je crains que ça ne
soit pas le cas
mais en tous les cas merci monsieur mise
votre exposé je serai très rapide cela a
été évoqué par mon collègue du cantal
tout à l'heure on est des situations
différentes et les territoires notamment
de montagne sont particulièrement
impactés par les décisions regretté est
regrettable de fermeture des remontées
mécaniques impact particulièrement les
départements de montagne
à titre d'exemple si d'affaires du
tourisme dans mon département et deux
milliard d'euros et mobilise 15000
emplois pour cent quarante mille
habitants avec 390 mille lits
touristiques de difficultés la première
sur la diversification
je constate que certaines entreprises
sur des filières qui ne sont pas
touristique ont déposé des demandes de
financement dans cas du plan de relance
soit n'ont pas eu de réponse soit ils
ont eu des réponses négatives
aujourd'hui sans qu'on ait forcément les
explications nécessaires pour rassurer
les entrepreneurs qui dans la période de
dépression veulent comme investir et
préparer le rebond la sortie de la crise
et d'autre part sans capacité non
seulement de leur donner des réponses
mélo mais les explications donc
j'apprécierais tout particulièrement les
instructions soient données dans les
services déconcentrés de l'état pour
qu'on puisse avoir des réponses très
précis sur les réseaux de roger éventuel
de deux sollicitations financières
la deuxième chose la concerne les
collectivités locales
je crois qu'en la formule devenue très
visité des trous dans la raquette
demeure et je constate qu'un certain
nombre de collectivités locales avec des
modes de gestion un peu spécifique je
pense notamment aux services publics
industriels commerciaux sur la gestion
de remontées mécaniques et de parkings
adossés à ces remontées mécaniques ne
bénéficient pas d'accompagnement
financier de l'état pour compenser les
pertes et cela met et cela altère la
capacité d'autofinancement et donc de
robben ces collectivités locales pour
accompagner le plan de relance le moment
venu donc j'aimerais là aussi que l'on
puisse améliorer ainsi possible la
méthode de travail pour pouvoir rassurer
ces collectivités locales et éviter que
par effet domino des faillites entraîne
d'autres faillites dans des territoires
particulièrement marqué par cette
décision gouvernementale
particulièrement dure en matière de
protection sanitaire de nos territoires
de montagne de leurs économies et
également de l'attractivité de ces
territoires
merci merci jean michel monsieur le
ministre pour essayer de répondre
rapidement et synthétiquement à
l'ensemble de ces questions
merci merci monsieur le président je
vais peut-être des réponses globales
vais te donner le temps dont je dispose
que j'ai un entretien que la commissaire
malgré de vesta guerre dans quelques
instants
et beaucoup de questions importantes ont
été posées d'après sur des questions
très particulière de dossiers locaux
n'hésitez pas à m'écrire sur le sujet à
chaque fois évidemment je regarde si les
dossiers doivent être revues stéphane
ceaux tard elle a cité le projet de bio
je rappelle juste que sur l'intégralité
des projets de relocalisation dans les
secteurs stratégiques
nous avons près de 900 projets qui ont
été déposés devant retenir deux sans
aucune sélection qui est importante
le projet de bio été redéposé à une
forme différente et améliorer donc je
crois que c'est vraiment le rôle des
élus de relayer des projets qui aurait
été retoqué par l'administration dont
vous estimez que malgré tout il mérite
d'être réévalué et regarder à nouveau je
le ferai évidemment à chaque fois pour
répondre peut-être pour commencer par
les remarques de roger karoutchi dont je
reconnais bien l'optimisme fervent et la
lucidité également malheureusement
l'honnêteté m'oblige à le dire je
rappelle juste que nous travaillons sur
un certain nombre de scénarios et que
j'ai un scénario de référence qu'est
celui d'une amélioration de la situation
économique à partir de la moitié de
l'année 2021 une dernière partie de
l'année 2000 21 qui devrait permettre à
l'économie française de rebondir fort je
travaille aussi sur d'autres scénarios
dont j'espère qu'ils resteront des
scénarios purement spéculatif me sall
l'économie des finances et pas des
réalités mais je reconnais bien
volontiers que le virus nous a tous
appris l'humilité et l'obligation de
considérer plusieurs options est de ne
jamais s'enfermer dans une option unique
en tout cas ce serait responsable du
point de vue financier de ne pas
considérer toutes les options y compris
effectivement celle que vous avez
présenté c'est à dire
une nouvelle vague d'une nouvelle
dégradation la situation est donc un
impact plus fort sur la situation
financière du pays
ce qui nous amènera je leur dis à chaque
fois à veiller à soutenir tous ceux qui
sont le plus en difficulté et ceux qui
sont les plus touchés par la crise
s'agissant du chômage laci on regarde
les choses de manière honnête c'est à
dire avec les chiffres qui nous ont été
communiqués
nous avons une situation qui a été moins
dégradés que prévu
tout simplement parce que l'économie
française après avoir détruit plus de
700 mille emplois a montré sa capacité
en recréé près de 500000 au moment du
rebond économique
donc je leur dis parce que ça pour le
coup c'est une conviction très ferme
la france a des fondamentaux économiques
solides et josé capacité de rebond
exceptionnel
on peut encore les améliorer ses
objectifs du plan de relance elle doit
se déployer vers de nouveaux secteurs
d'activité ça c'est absolument vital
à mes yeux il est impératif d'ouvrir et
je vais venir aux questions très
pertinentes qui m'ont été posées de
nouveaux champs et de nouveaux secteurs
d'activité mais les fondamentaux sont
bons nous avons amélioré la
compétitivité l'économie française
réduit la fiscalité qui pesait sur les
ménages et sur les entreprises améliorer
le fonctionnement du marché du travail
réinvesti dans l'industrie former de
nouvelles compétences tout ça doit nous
permettre de rebondir fort je rappelle
que nous sommes entrés en crise ennuyant
l'un des meilleurs taux de croissance de
la zone euro et un chômage qui avait
baissé de près de deux points
donc nous avions la possibilité de
redresser notre économie parce que les
fondamentaux avaient été améliorés qui
sont désormais solidement j'en viens
justement à la question qui a été posée
par parce que ça vaut le dédit sur la
réindustrialisation c'est pour moi un
enjeu absolument critique de ne pas
sortir de la crise avec la même économie
que celle que nous avions avant il faut
qu'au sortir de la crise nous tirions
les leçons de ce que nous avons connu
pour avoir une économie qui réduisent
les inégalités
qu'ils soient davantage décarbonés et
qu'ils soient plus diversifiée si en
sorte de l'économie de la crise actuelle
en se disant en est reparti sur les
énergies fossiles
on va refaire exactement comme avant
avec le même type de croissance et le
même type de modèle économique
mais ce sera un échec historique c'est
pas ça ce que nous voulons faire
nous voulons utiliser cette crise comme
une opportunité pour améliorer notre
modèle économique dans un sens de plus
de compétitivité plus de diversité et
plus de protection climatique
quand vous citer l'exemple de la santé
des biotechnologies je partage
totalement dans le plan de relance
notamment dans le pays à nous avons mis
beaucoup d'argent ça et biotechnologies
sur l'immunothérapie sur les
technologies de santé de pointe de la
digitalisation de la santé parce que ses
clés pour réduire les dépenses et les
rendre plus efficaces en matière de
dépenses de santé et c'est absolument
décisif pour réindustrialiser le pays
sur des champs d'avenir je partage
totalement votre analyse
la santé est un des champs de triel
d'avenir pour le pays et il reste encore
beaucoup à faire pour investir dans ces
domaines là autre exemple électronique
ou de les citer moi je suis favorable à
ce qu'il y ait un programme d'intérêt
commun européen sur les microprocesseurs
il ya un grand débat pour savoir si on
fait du rouz mm du 5 mm ou du 2 mm moi
je suis favorable à ce que nous ayons
les microprocesseurs qui soient les plus
pointus possibles même si
l'investissement à chaque fois est
exponentielle au fur et à mesure qu'on
réduit la taille mais nous avons une
filière industrielle là dedans qui est
performante
donc nous devons continuer à investir et
diversifié pour avoir dans le domaine de
la microélectronique
une filière qui soit la plus efficace
possible qu'elles sont du coup les
règles qui président à cette
industrialisation avait tout de suite
vous rassurer c'est pas les économies
des finances qui tout seul dans son
bureau dit dans un claquement de doigts
tient à faire telle filière ou telle
filière
absolument pas c'est une démarche qui
vient de la base qui vient du terrain et
qu'il correspond à un certain nombre de
critères et ses critères d'aidé fixé par
les industriels par des scientifiques
pas mais cherche
heures et pas par des politiques je vais
être très clair là-dessus ce que je
pense que c'est très important ce ne
sont pas des choix politiques se sont
d'abord des choix scientifiques
industrielles et économiques notamment
menée par monsieur gauthier le président
d'air liquide et par l'ensemble du
conseil national de l'industrie qui a
fait des propositions ont été validées
ensuite présenté au parlement
nous sommes en démocratie c'est le
peuple qui décide mais la méthode n'est
pas la méthode des années 60
effectivement j'ai eu 60 le politique
dit on va être développées telles
filières et puis ça suit derrière
nous avons adopté une démarche
radicalement différente qui part de la
base des scientifiques des industriels
du monde économique qui est instruite
par le comité national chargé de
l'industrie est ensuite validé au niveau
politique et présenté aux parlementaires
quelles sont les conditions qu'il faut
remplir la première c'est qu'il y ait un
marché donc il ya eu des études de
marché pour savoir est ce qu'il ya un
marché sur l'hydrogène ça rien développé
l'hydrogène pour développer hydrogène la
réponse est oui il ya un marché par
exemple sur les avions
et je pense qu'airbus peut-être le
premier avionneur la planète a développé
un avion fonctionnant à l'hydrogène et
émettant zéro co2 c'est la première
condition y at il un marché
y at il un marché ses microprocesseurs
oui y at il un marché sur les
biotechnologies oui y at il un marché
sur l'oncologie de pointe adaptées à
l'adn de chaque personne oui y at il un
marché sur la physique quantique oui
c'est probablement beaucoup plus
important encore que l'intelligence
artificielle et nous avons là dessus un
atout absolument considérable présent la
république a annoncé que nous mettrions
près de 2 milliards sur cette filière
c'est le point d'aboutissement de tout
le travail qui a été fait première
question y at il des marchés sur tous
les secteurs que j'indiquais oui il y à
des marchés disponibles qui permette
d'avoir de la croissance
deuxième condition avons nous des
industries de base pour développer ces
technologies
soit on va pas prendre de nulle part une
technologie en soutien à investir
massivement là dessus si vous n'avez pas
l'industrie de bah ça ne sert à rien
arriverait pas dans les délais qui sont
les nôtres je reprends les ans de
l'hydrogène vous avez avec makfi
spécialiste des valves vous avez avec
les reliques id des industries
françaises qui ont déjà la compétence
pour franchir l'étape suivante qui va
être l'électro lise la séparation de
l'hydrogène et de l'oxygène pour
fabriquer de l'hydrogène et qui nous
permettra ensuite d'avoir des capacités
totalement décarbonée donc il faut avoir
un outil industriel c'est la deuxième
condition est ce que nous l'avons
également dans le domaine des
biotechnologies de la santé et là la
réponse est de toute évidence oui
s'agissant la microélectronique je
rappelle que avant à crolles avec st
micro et les entreprises les plus
performants de la planète
donc ça vaut le coup de continuer à se
déployer sur ce secteur-là
c'est la deuxième condition la troisième
position est ce que nous avons les
compétences
il faut un marché faut des industries il
faut les compétences et des formations
nous allons ouvrir des filières de
formation sur tous ces secteurs de
réindustrialisation que nous avons prévu
parce que l'on sait bien que le premier
obstacle à la réindustrialisation au
delà de la question des coûts c'est les
compétences et tous les industriels que
vous consultez régulièrement sur le
terrain de vous dire la même chose
on cherche des compétences dans tel ou
tel domaine on les trouve pas donc il
faut forme
enfin une dernière condition c'est y at
il un soutien européen
parce que surtout ces filières de
relocalisation industrielle de
réindustralisation le chiffre de
référence c'est pas le million d'euros
c'est pas la centaine de millions
d'euros
c'est le milliard milliards d'euros
l'unité de compte des stratégies de
création de nouvelles chaînes de valeur
quand renault décide d'investir sur de
nouvelles batteries électriques c'est
plusieurs milliards d'euros quand nous
quittons la filière et batteries
électriques c'est plusieurs milliards
d'euros donc vous ne pouvez pas le faire
seul
il faut qu'il y ait aussi un engagement
européen sur toutes les filles que j'ai
cités l'hydrogène didot technologie des
batteries électriques le calcul
quantique
c'est une approche européenne et peut
être très simple principalement une
approche franco allemande
donc c'est d' un des enjeux historiques
le plus important qui se joue
aujourd'hui
basculer d'une économie qui depuis
trente ou quarante ans repose sur les
mêmes chaînes de valeur à une nouvelle
économie plus décarbonés
technologiquement plus avancés
ouvrant de nouvelles chaînes de valeur
pour la france et garantissant à nos
enfants et à nos petits enfants des
emplois et un niveau de vie suffisamment
élevé parce qu'il ya un lien direct
entre l'industrialisation du pays et le
niveau de vie du pays donc pardon
d'avoir un peu long sur ce sujet mais je
pense qu'il le mérite parce que c'est un
sujet extrêmement important sur des
questions qui m'ont été posées sur les
jeunes je rappelle ce qui a été fait à
l'été elles elles embauchent les aide à
l embauche de jeunes de moins de 26 ans
en cdi
les aides exceptionnelles pour les
jeunes précaires le renforcement des
dispositifs d'insertion d'accompagnement
comme la garantie jeunes dans les plats
sont les dédoubler les aides financières
spécifiques lit le repas par jour à 1
d'euros quand est annoncé par le
président de la république mais je redis
que nous sommes ouverts à l'étude
d'autres dispositifs
monsieur guérini a proposé encore
récemment la possibilité d'avoir un
capital jeunes de départ de 10000 euros
qui seraient remboursés uniquement
lorsque la personne qui en profiteraient
auraient un emploi qui lui permettrait
de rembourser dans de bonnes conditions
je trouve que c'est une idée
intéressante qui le méritent d'être
étudiées et retenue s'agissant des
quartiers prioritaires de la ville
madame la sénatrice
nous avons un comité interministériel à
ville qui va se tenir vendredi
il y aura un suivi de cet engagement je
sais que c'est un engagement important
qui vous tient à coeur
nadia est pleinement mobilisée sur ce
sujet notamment avec madame bornes et
nous avons dans le plan de relance je
crois des réponses très concrètes à
cette question importante du quartier
prioritaire de la vie la modernisation
de l'infrastructure insertion par
l'emploi ou 500 millions d'euros dégagés
pour la réhabilitation des logements
sociaux
sur la dette la question était posée par
plusieurs d'entre vous ont fini peu
d'alliés notamment monsieur kahn devait
également et d'autres parmi vous quand
je dis que je n'ai pas d'inquiétude pour
notre dette c'est tout simplement parce
que nous avons une capacité à lever de
la dette sur les marchés qui aujourd'hui
et je m'exprime au nom du trésor de
l'agencé france trésor ne rencontrent
aucune difficulté
j'ai lu les mêmes magazine que vous j'ai
vu les alertes qui sont tirées par
certains je pense qu'elles ne
correspondent pas à la réalité de ce que
je vis comme ministre qui a la tutelle
de l'agencé france trésor et qui a la
responsabilité de lever de l'argent sur
les marchés si la situation était
différente je vous le dirai mais il se
trouve que ces propos sont sanctionnés
par des chiffres si la france avait des
difficultés à lever de la dette sur les
marchés
cela se traduirait par un spread
beaucoup plus élevé avec l'allemagne et
par les taux d'intérêt très différent de
ce que nous avons je rappelle également
pour eux ce qu'ils 120 kg est que nous
empruntons toujours à taux fixe et donc
si jamais de hier une hausse des taux
d'intérêt elle n'aurait n'a pas sur le
coût de la dette que progressivement
l'eau si tout ce qu'ils nous disent tout
d'un coup ça va augmenter
il a la charge de la dette va exploser
ce n'est pas la vérité partir du moment
nous empruntons à taux fixe l'ensemble
de ce qu'il peut emprunter sera
remboursé à taux fixe et sur les
nouvelles levée de dette qui pourrait y
avoir une augmentation mais uniquement
sur les nouvelles émissions de dette
je pense de manière plus globale que dia
la vérité ne veut pas dire jouer avec
les peurs des français
personne ne l'a fait dans cette salle
dans cette commission vous en remercie
mais je pense que c'est notre
responsabilité politique de dire
sincèrement la vérité aux français mais
sans jouer avec leurs peurs la france
n'a pas de problème pour le lait de la
dette et il n'y aura pas d'impact brutal
sur le niveau de remboursement de cette
dette dès lors que les émissions et les
emprunts sont faits à taux fixe
troisième élément et ça rejoint des
remarques ont été faites notamment par
monsieur d'allier c'est que bien entendu
ce raisonnement de se tient qu'à partir
devant
pour le ministre des finances français
garantit aux marchés le remboursement de
cette dette dans des délais qui peuvent
être des délais longs parce que chacun
sait que cela prendra du temps étant
donné le niveau de dette auquel nous
sommes parvenus et la garantie du
remboursement de la dette fait la
crédibilité de la signature française et
la crédibilité de cette garantie tient
aux mesures que nous proposons
croissance réduction des dépenses
publiques
le moment venu quand la croissance sera
de retour et réformes structurelles dont
la réforme des retraites
et pardon de le rappeler parfois avait
beaucoup d'obstination mais c'est aussi
ça qui fait que lorsque nous le devons
de l'argent sur les marchés
nous avons des investisseurs qui restent
intéressés par notre dette
enfin je veux signaler tous ceux qui
disent qu'on ne rembourseront pas la
dette qu'ils auront expliquer aux
français qui ont investi la dette
française qui je le rappelle est détenu
à 25% par des épargnants français qu'il
ne l'ait rembourseront pas le moment
venu je pense qu'ils seront très heureux
de l'apprendre
[Musique]